bitcoin you've probably heard about it
but what is it bitcoin is a
decentralized digital currency what does
that mean it is the exact opposite of
dollars the same dollars that you have
in your bank account or in your pocket
those dollars have an unlimited supply
and they're controlled by central banks
or governments that can print and create
as many of the dollars or currency as
they want whenever they want bitcoin is
the exact opposite it's a decentralized
digital currency that means that there's
an entire network of people around the
world that all use bitcoin and
participate in the network but nobody
controls it there's only 21 million
bitcoin that will ever be created and so
therefore no one can create more bitcoin
as a decentralized digital currency
protects your purchasing power it makes
everything around you become cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper over time dollars in
fiat currency are the exact opposite
those dollars become less valuable as
more and more are created over time and
therefore everything becomes more
expensive around you bitcoin a
decentralized digital currency coming to
a place near you
[Music]